Well, good morning church.
It's great to see you.
Uh, if you are new to our church, we're
so thankful you would take that step of faith to be here.
Uh, we know it's not easy to walk into a new place,
and so we're grateful for that.
Uh, please head to the new here area after this.
We'd love to meet you and get to know you
and help connect you to our church if we can.
Uh, so please let us have that opportunity.
Also, due to fall break this week,
we are not having Wednesday night gatherings here on campus,
but also in look in the app towards next Wednesday,
we're kicking off a new slate of equipping classes.
So make sure you look at those.
There's some exciting things in that as we kind of reset
after fall break into a new time for Wednesday nights.
And finally, excuse me, for members today is a, a big deal.
We are finalizing today the, the vote
for those elder candidates that we've been putting
before you for the last couple weeks.
So if you haven't already, you can, uh,
take your email you got on Thursday and you can vote there
or you can head out to the information desk
and make sure that you vote on, uh, those as we go to today.
So by the time we're done with the second service
around noon, uh, we'll close that.
And so if you get a chance to, as soon as we're done
with this head out there or pull open your email
and do that as we turn to God's word.
Now, let me invite you to take your copy of God's word
and open it to one Samuel chapter 12.
Maybe scroll down to one Samuel 12, however you use that.
It's early in the Bible. One Samuel
big number 12 is the chapter.
As we walk through this book, what we're gonna see today is
really kind of Samuel's farewell address.
It's not essentially that,
but we'll see that this, this prophet judge
that God had used to transition Israel from what it was
to a monarchy, uh, Samuel's kind
of fading to the background.
He's still gonna be involved as we go forward.
We'll see that, but he won't be as public.
And so this is kind of his last words you might say.
And the context of his speech is
that coronation ceremony we saw at the end
of chapter 11 last week where they gathered at Gilgal
and they renewed the kingdom is the way they put it.
And they worshiped the Lord. They sacrificed to the Lord.
They crowned Saul officially is the king.
This is the context, is what Samuel then turns
that into is in a sense like a covenant renewal ceremony,
where they were reminded who they were
as God's people, including
reminded about how far they've drifted away from
that reality, that they drifted so far,
that they even asked for a king instead
of trusting God as their king.
And so this moment of covenant renewal is kind
of the question like, okay, is this thing even gonna work?
We've seen the problems already. Is this thing gonna work?
Is monarchy even where God wants this to go?
Well look at Samuel's words starting in verse
one, chapter 12.
And Samuel said to all Israel, behold,
I have obeyed your voice and all that you've said
to me made a king over you.
And now behold, the king walks before you, meaning he's here
and I am old and gray and behold my sons are with you.
I've walked before you from my youth until this day.
Here I am testify against me
before the Lord, before is anointed.
Whose ox have I taken? Whose donkey have I taken?
Whom have I defrauded?
Whom have I oppressed or from whose hand have I taken a
bribe to blind my eyes with it, testify against me,
I'll restore it to you.
And they said, you have not defrauded us or oppressed us
or taken anything from any man's hand.
And he said to them, the Lord is witness against you
and is anointed as a witness against you this day
that you have not found anything in my hand.
And they said, he is witness.
Now, we'll stop there for a moment
because what's happening here at the beginning
of this covenant renewal ceremony,
we learned something from this.
The first thing, what Samuel's doing here is it's showing us
his Godly leadership.
We learn about this right off the bat.
We learn about Samuel's godly leadership in the nation.
Now, some people might feel like he's boasting.
He he's not boasting here.
He's just merely asking them to confirm
that he was above reproach.
What was was I who I said I was?
You've watched me from when I was a child in the tabernacle.
Am I who I say I am? Have you watched me?
Have you seen me?
And they had to say yes because he had been doing that.
You might say he's in this doing something more than just
kind of getting this affirmation.
He's setting an example
for every leader who would follow him.
Every priest, every prophet, every king, even
that he's not gonna be perfect,
but he has to set an example of Godly leadership
and lead in that kind of way.
So that's the first thing we learned. But that wasn't all.
Look now as we continue verses six through 11,
Samuel gives him a little history lesson.
Samuel said to the people, the Lord is witness
who appointed Moses and Aaron
and brought your fathers up outta the land of Egypt.
Now therefore, stand still that I may plead with you
before the Lord concerning all the righteous deeds
of the Lord that he performed for you and your fathers.
When Jacob went into Egypt
and the Egyptians oppressed them,
then your fathers cried out to the Lord.
The Lord sent Moses and Aaron who brought your fathers out
of Egypt, made them dwell in this place,
but they forgot the Lord their God.
And he sold them into the hand of Cicero, commander
of the army of Hazo into the hand of the Philistines,
into the hand of the king of Moab.
They fought against them and they cried out to the Lord
and said, we have sinned because we have forsaken the Lord
and have served the Baals and the Aral,
but now deliver us outta the hand of our enemies
that we may serve you.
And the Lord sent j Baal and Barak and Jeff Thaw
and Samuel, those were all judges
and delivered you out of the hand
of your enemies on every side, and you lived in safety.
So here Samuel, what he does is he walks
through the history of Israel.
What he does here is he showed God's gracious
provision for the people.
He was reminding them of God's gracious provision
over the many generations before them.
He recounted to the Israelites, God's faithfulness,
the righteous deeds of the Lord.
It says to them, to their ancestors, how God had
provided for them over and over
and over, how God had delivered his people from slavery in
Egypt, how God had used the judges
to deliver them from his enemies
around them in the promised land.
And not only did God deliver them from these people,
God also provided this land for them
that they're now living in.
Like you just see his gracious provision.
Yet in the same section
you see God's gracious provision,
but you also see Israel's shaky faith in the middle
of it, right?
You saw it right? You saw God's gracious provision.
You saw how shaky their faith was in response.
Now, that's a theme throughout the Old Testament
where even though the Israelites had seen God do amazing
things in Egypt, they so quickly forgot God.
Like just think about what they saw.
They saw plagues fall on their enemies.
Instead of them, they saw their
sons spared.
If all they did was put some blood
of the lamb on their doorpost,
they saw the Red Sea split wide open.
Yet over and over, those same people
were afraid of what lay ahead like that.
They'd seen it. And
yet they walked in terror of what could happen.
It says the way that the way it says it, God delivered them
yet verse nine, they forgot the Lord their God
and turned to idols.
They just forgot all that God had done.
Even after he disciplined them,
he turned their hearts back to him.
They lived in relative safety for a while in the land.
What happened? Verse 12.
And when you saw that ash, remember snake, the king
of the Ammonites came against you.
You said to me, no,
but a king shall reign over us
when the Lord your God was your king.
Same song. Second verse, they'd forgotten
all that God had done for them to get them to the place
where they were to deliver them.
They forgot that he had spared them.
They forgot all that he'd done,
and they were immediately afraid again.
So that give us a king, we need somebody to protect us
when God had done it over and over and over.
So Israel's faith in Yahweh wavered a lot
through this process, which is why God
brought his holy justice.
You see that here, God's holy justice.
I'm gonna read a chunk of this now verses 13 through 25,
and I want you to look for
holy justice in these verses.
Look for that concept of you reap what you sow.
Look for the idea of God's holy justice,
that he doesn't just sweep sin under the rug.
Watch this. Verse 13.
And now behold the king whom you have chosen
for whom you've asked, behold the
Lord has set a king over you.
If you will fear the Lord and serve him and obey his voice
and not rebel against the commandment of the Lord.
And if both you and the king reigns over,
you will follow the Lord your God.
It will be well. But if you will not obey the voice
of the Lord, but rebel against the commandment of the Lord,
then the hand of the Lord will be against you and your king.
Now therefore, stand still
and see this great thing
that the Lord will do before your eyes.
Is it not wheat harvest Today, I will call upon the Lord
that he may send thunder and rain and you shall know
and see that your wickedness is great,
which you have done in the sight
of the Lord in asking for yourselves a king.
So Samuel called upon the Lord.
The Lord sent thunder and rain that day
and all the people greatly feared the Lord and Samuel
and all the people said to Samuel, pray for your servants
to the Lord your God that we may not die for we have added
to all our sins, this evil to ask for ourselves a king.
And Samuel said to the people, do not be afraid.
You have done all this evil
yet do not turn aside from following the Lord,
but serve the Lord with all your heart and do not turn aside
after empty things that cannot profit
or deliver for they're empty.
For the Lord will not forsake his people
for his great namesake
because it is please the Lord
to make you a people for himself.
Moreover, as for me, far be it for me
that I should sin against the Lord
by ceasing to pray for you.
I will instruct you in the good, in the right way,
only fear the Lord
and serve him faithfully with all your heart for consider
what great things he has done for you.
But if you still do wickedly, you shall be swept away,
both you and your king.
So you see it here, right?
Samuel's recounting the obligations they had,
the responsibilities they had under this covenant with God,
and we see God's holy justice throughout it.
It's pretty simple, right? If they obey the voice
of the Lord, things will go well.
If they don't, then the hand of the Lord will be against you
and your king, right?
If they turn, if they turn aside to things, empty things
that will not profit
or deliver, the Lord's hand of justice will come on them
and will sweep them away.
In fact, this storm that comes here in verses 16
through 18 is illustration of that justice.
Now, I love storms.
I wanted to be a storm chaser when I grew up.
Still kind of do in some ways.
We would do this out in small town, western Oklahoma.
We would chase storms on our own. We would do that.
Thankfully, never got anything too serious.
But we would do that.
And I love the image, I love the power of God
that you can see in thunderstorms.
But this one here in one Samuel was not God merely showing
off, which he kind of think maybe does sometimes.
This storm was very specific.
'cause notice in verse 17, it pinpoints
that it was at the wheat harvest.
Now why is that significant?
First, because there weren't many
storms at the time of the harvest.
This would've been rare. And
so there was clearly a miraculous moment.
Even the fact that Samuel prayed
and it happened was part of that, but also
because if a storm would come at the time of harvest,
there was a real threat of starvation for the people
because the the wheat was ready to be plucked.
And if the storm comes
and destroys it, knocks it all to the ground.
They can't get it to eat it.
And so what Samuel's illustrating here
with the storm is this threat of judgment.
If they continued to in sin, this was going to happen.
Starvation and famine was evidence
of God's judgment on people at times.
So it could ruin the grain, it could lead to justice.
So he's saying if you continue in sin, you would be judged.
Listen, we cannot trifle with God's holiness.
We can't treat him as if he is not going to be
just his.
People are to be faithful to him.
Now I, I said it earlier that Samuel kind of fades
to the background of the narrative.
From this point forward, we'll see Saul rise.
We'll see some things with David eventually,
but know that Samuel's not absent in this whole process.
In fact, you see what Samuel said in verse 23.
Look at it again. It says,
moreover, as for me, far be it for me
that I should sin against the Lord by ceasing to pray
for you, and I will instruct you in the good
and the right way.
So Samuel doesn't just fade in the background, he shifts.
His role is different.
Now, from this point forward, we see that he is
to fully lean into the role of prophet.
This was his clarified new role.
He kind of played a different judge like role almost king,
like in a sense almost priest like at times
now he's saying, I'm just gonna be the prophet.
My role is to be the prophet.
A prophet was to pray for the nation
and to be the mouthpiece of God, both for the people
and for the king to instruct them
in God's way.
So in essence, what would happen from this point forward is
that the there, there was a split now
between the civic duties of the king
and the spiritual duties of the prophet.
Again, it had kind of been blended together in one person
for a while in some weird ways, but,
but now it's going to split.
And this whole thing called the monarchy would not work
if either side didn't fulfill their function.
That if they, if the prophet doesn't do his job,
the king doesn't do his job the way they're supposed to or,
and this will be kind of foreshadowing,
or if they started to try to cross over into the other role,
if the king started to do some prophet like stuff,
the prophet tried to be the king, like it didn't work.
But this was Samuel's new role.
He was to remind the king, to remind the people
that God was actually still their king.
They had a king on earth, but God still the true king
and that they needed to fulfill the covenant,
the responsibilities of that.
It's what Samuel does here, right?
He instructs them in
what they should be doing and what they shouldn't be.
Yet there's one more thing we see learn in in
this covenant renewal ceremony.
What we learn from it, you see it at the top of your notes,
even I, I put Joel two 13 on there for a reason.
You see this idea in that verse.
You see it in one Samuel 12.
What we learn is that God's mercy is abundant.
We learn that here. As harsh as this sounds,
God's abundant mercy is clear throughout this passage
like we saw in how God responded to the people in Egypt.
When they cried out for freedom
and deliverance, what did he do?
He delivered them.
We saw in how God responded to the people in the land.
They're oppressed by these
enemies that are coming their way.
They cried out to God. What did he do? He delivered them.
He even gave them a king knowing
that in the process they were rejecting him as their king.
He still mercifully gave them a king.
Yet we see it very clearly starting in verse 19.
Remember, they just experienced this storm that was in kind
of an allusion to justice.
They'd seen God's holy power. And what did they do?
They recognized their sin.
Verse 19, the people said to Samuel, pray for your servants
to the Lord your God, that we may not die for we have added
to all our sins, this evil, to ask for ourselves a king.
They recognize their sin. They cried out to God.
Watch God's mercy.
Now, verse 20, Samuel said to the people, do not be afraid.
Do not be afraid. He acknowledged now.
Now he acknowledged they did it
and he acknowledged they shouldn't keep doing it.
But verse 22, here's why they shouldn't fear.
Look at verse 22. For the Lord will not forsake his people
for his great name's sake,
because it has pleased the Lord to make you a people
for himself.
That's mercy, isn't it?
See, here's the definition of mercy,
not giving someone what they deserve.
Grace is giving someone what they don't deserve.
Mercy is not giving them.
What they do deserve is, is
that not what God did for Israel?
Right? Remember, this is a sinful,
rebellious people
who regularly turn their back on their king.
And what did he do? He mercifully delivered them,
redeemed them, saved them.
That's who God is. This is
what we learned from this whole scene about all who God is.
So cool story, right? Good for them.
What does this have to do with us? Right?
That's the, that's one of the hard parts.
I said this at the very beginning of the series
of dealing with the Old Testaments.
Like, okay, well, got got them where they need to be.
What do we, what about us? How do we apply this?
Like how does this carry forward into
Tuesday afternoon at work
or Saturday night, whenever you're gonna choose to do it?
Like how does this matter? We need to figure that out.
Well, we look for principles, right?
I found at least three you could probably find some more
that we could take away from all of this.
Three principles. Here's the first one,
in faith, we ought
to recount God's goodness
Recount God's goodness.
See, why did Samuel tell them all these old stories?
Because he wanted to reorient their minds around all
that God had done for them.
He wanted to remind them of
how God had delivered their people from slavery in Egypt.
how God had saved them from their enemies.
And he wanted to remind them that all that deliverance came
when they trusted God alone, when they cried out to God,
when they leaned on God.
Because in the moment they were shaky,
their foundation was shifting.
And he says this to them, saying, all you need to do, guys,
all you need to do is go back
and look at God's goodness to you over and over and over.
And that would reassure their trembling hearts.
Do we not need to do the same thing?
So often in our lives, like we look around
and it starts to get a little
shaky, starts to get a little worried.
We look at our future, we look at the world, we're like,
oh man, this is, this is gonna be bad.
Samuel said, the reason that they asked
for a king in the first place was
because they'd forgotten
how God had delivered them over and over and over, over.
The reason you and I look for replacement kings look
for replacement saviors is because we forget who God is
and what He's done over and over and over in our lives.
We forget that he has
provided for us financially when it sure seemed impossible.
I forget that He has gotten me
through every situation I've ever faced in my life.
You forget that nations and leaders rise
and fall, yet the church stands forever.
And we get shaky and we look and we need a replacement king.
We need a replacement savior.
And, and we, we look for this stuff instead
of remembering who God is.
But most of all, here's, I love this phrase from Paul Tripp.
Most of all, we have gospel amnesia
that we forget all that God has done
to save our souls.
The most important thing he's ever done for us.
We forget that if we have placed our faith in Jesus' life,
death, and resurrection in our place,
that he's fully covered our sin forever and ever.
He loves us. He cherishes us.
He knows us, and he's given us a home with him forever.
We forget that.
That's why we sing the gospel here.
That's why we preach the gospel here.
That's why we pray the gospel here.
That's why we talk about it all the time,
because we are prone to forget the works of God
and all that he has done for us.
So when we recount his goodness
to us, it builds our faith.
It builds the faith of those around us as they hear
what God has done over and over and over in his goodness.
Because we believe,
because we have faith, we recount his goodness to us.
Here's a second principle in this chapter.
In life, we are
to obey God's commands in life.
We are to obey God's commands.
I know it seems simplistic,
but it's all over this passage, isn't it?
Just a few things he says, verse 14, fear the Lord.
Serve him. Obey his voice.
Don't rebel against the commandment of the Lord.
Verse 15, he actually says the same things,
but he flips it around negatively.
Verse 20, don't turn aside from following the Lord.
Serve the Lord with all your heart. Verse 21.
Don't turn aside from the Lord.
Lord, after all these empty things.
Verse 24, fear the Lord.
Serve him faithfully with all your heart.
Verse 25, he flips it around,
says, here's what happens if you don't.
Right? It's all over this.
It's the same thing that Jesus taught us as Christians.
Matthew 22 verses 37 through 40,
what we now know to be the great commandment,
Jesus says this, you shall love the Lord your God
with all your heart and with all your soul
and with all your mind.
This is the great and first commandment.
And a second is like it.
You shall love your neighbor
as yourself on these two commandments.
Depend all the law and the prophets.
Sounds like the same thing Samuel says in one Samuel 12.
Love the Lord your God with everything you are
above everything else, and love your neighbor as yourself.
That's all it takes.
It's the same thing that Jesus said in Matthew 28,
that is a part of disciple making.
He says, teach them to obey all that I've commanded you.
It's even in John 1415 where Jesus said, if you love me,
you will keep my commandments.
He says that to them basically
as an expectation you should obey
and a promise that you will,
that God will do something in your heart,
that he will lead you to obedience of his commandments.
Here's the principle in one Samuel 12 is he says it over
and over, that life goes better when we serve the Lord
with all our hearts, when we obey him.
I'm not saying life will be perfect when you do that,
but it sure goes better.
The world is fallen, your body's broken.
It won't work perfectly, but it sure will go better.
'cause we need to remember what Galatians six says.
Do not be deceived.
God is not mocked for whatever one sows, plants
that will he also reap for the one who sows
to his own flesh, will from the flesh reap corruption,
but the one who sows to the spirit will from the spirit
reap eternal life.
Holiness matters, right?
Holiness matters. So here's the challenge.
Let's be marked not just
by what we are against.
Let's not just be marked by
how loudly we talk about politics on social media.
Let's be known by how faithfully
we obey all that Jesus commanded us to do.
That would be shocking to the world, man.
They really believe this stuff, don't they?
They really obey this. It's amazing.
Yet here, here's what I felt as I wrote that,
that section about obeying his commands.
I, I had kind of a,
a latent discouragement even as I wrote that.
I know it's true. I know I'm supposed to, I know it's right,
but I I, I felt discouraged even as I wrote it
and even as I say it,
because I know how poorly I do at that.
I, I praise God
that it's not blatant sin anymore, right?
Used to be, not anymore just blatant sin.
Praise God that that's not there.
But now it's a lot more subtle.
It, it's the good. I'm not doing that.
I know I'm supposed to. It's the love
that I'm not showing to someone when I know I should be.
That's that's there. It's under the, the layers.
It's there though. And so I look at one Samuel 12,
I look at Galatians six.
I know that sometimes my motivations are bad
for even doing good things,
and I know I'm not fully obeying all of his commands.
And so I'm discouraged by that. So what's left for me?
Love the Lord, you, God, with all your heart.
I'm like, man, this morning I didn't even do that. Right?
Like, what's left?
Here's the prime, the the final principle today, praise God
for this in sin,
trust God's mercy in sin.
Trust God's mercy.
When you're confronted with your sin that is face to face
with you every day, trust, lean into God's mercy.
You remember what happened for them in one Samuel 12, they
recognize their sin.
They cried out to the Lord,
and Samuel reminded them of God's mercy to them.
And again, don't forget who these people were.
This was Israel who over
and over had forsaken God.
Yet still, it says very clearly,
God will not forsake his people, the people he was pleased
to make for himself.
What grace and mercy, right?
Do you see how he didn't give them what they deserved?
He could've wiped him off the, the face of the map said,
you've all turned away from me.
You all deserve my wrath. And you're done.
And what did he do? No, no. He delivered.
He redeemed, he saved.
And listen, that's even more true for you today.
If you have turned from your sin and yourself,
and you have placed your faith in the grace
and mercy of Jesus in your place, what that means is
that you are his.
Now, what that means is that he has made you,
he has made you a new creation through the life, death,
and resurrection of Jesus Christ.
It means you are His.
And listen to how one Peter two says this,
you are a chosen race, a royal priesthood,
a holy nation of people for his own possession,
so that you may proclaim the excellencies of him
who called you out of darkness into his marvelous light.
Listen to this. Once you were not a people,
but now you are God's people.
Once you had not received mercy,
but now you have received mercy.
So friend, lean into that mercy,
lean into that.
Like Joel two says on your notes, return to him.
Return to him remembering who God is, remembering
who you are, and remembering whose you are.
Amen. Return to him.
Remember, he has made you His by the mercy
of Jesus', precious blood shed for you.
That was the purchase price to make you his
and to make you new.
Which leads us back to one Samuel 1222.
The Lord will not forsake his people.
And do you remember why He wouldn't
for his great names' sake.
He will not forsake his people for his great names' sake,
for his glory.
Hear me, hear me.
You might be really on the edge of this right now
for his glory.
He will not kick you out when you sin.
You catch that 'cause you're going
to, he knew you would.
Yet, if you are his, he will not kick you out
for his names sake.
So hear me, let that draw you in today.
Let that draw you into his mercy
and then let that compel us to live a life
that's completely different because of his mercy.
Let's pray. Ask him for that help.
God, I thank you for your word.
I thank you that you have the
infinite level of mercy that we can't even fathom
for sinners like us.
Thank you God. And I know there can be
a, a heavy weight of shame
that the enemy tosses on our shoulders every
moment of our lives.
And he's not lying to us.
God, we, we acknowledge that
what the enemy tells us we've done is true.
Yet confession, Jesus confession is agreeing with that
and saying, it's yours, God, we give it to you.
We run back to you
that your mercy means you don't forsake your people.
And if we've trusted you, God, I pray for our faith family
that we would run to you in faith.
Recounting your goodness, walking in holiness,
yet leaning on your mercy.
Thank you for that grace. Hope us see that today.
In Jesus' name. Amen.
Listen, all of that is.